the result in cumberland is really
fantastic got a brilliant team of
candidates here very very positive
campaign and it shows we can win
in cumberland it's really important to
me to the labour party to act uh to our
candidates and of course there are key
seats that sit in this area that we need
for the general election it's not just
cumberland because we're winning across
the country as well winning in the south
and in london but this is really this
cumberland win is very significant for
us
are these results really good enough
though especially against a backdrop of
party gate and a cost of living crisis
this is a real turning point for the
labour party um we've shown we can win
that we could win in the north in
cumberland here with key constituencies
sitting behind these wins in the north
roslindale's just come in we've shown
also we can win in the south in
southampton we took southampton
overnight and then of course historic
wins in london seats that it was said
labour could never gain and so we've got
the wind in our sails we're on the march
and we've got the next general election
very firmly in our sights you are still
a long way though from winning a general
election from the depths of despair in
2019 to these wins in these elections is
a huge progress in the two years that
we've had um and now we're winning we
can show we can win in the north we've
shown we can win in the south historic
wins in london and wind in our sails uh
we're on the march to that next
generation general election
outside london in the red wall you
haven't seen a big breakthrough actually
your your vote share is down
that must be worrying why do you think
you've failed to make that headway well
we've just taken uh cumberland which is
significant for us rosendale result has
just come in as well another significant
win for us so i don't accept this
argument we're not winning across the
country we are winning across the
country um after the depths of despair
in 29 this is very very significant a
real turning point we put down solid
foundations shown we can win in the
north show we can win in the south
winning of course historically in london
um and with that positivity we now go
forward to the general election
what about you personally are you
failing to win over voters we've just
won in cumberland we've just won in
southampton we've just won in roslindale
we've just taken three london boroughs
wandsworth they always said label will
never get wandsworth we've just done it
westminster never been labor before so
this is a real turning point for us
we've had really hard work over the last
couple of years we've changed our party
put down very solid foundations and we
now build on that